nicolas hervé je suis chercheur à l'inrs
a retravaillé globalement sur les objets
de l'ina les archives télévision radio
ça va de la préservation de la
restauration des contenus mais également
l'aide à la documentation et à
l'indexation et puis tout ce qui
concerne la valorisation de ces archives
auprès des différents publics de l'ina
et dont notamment les chercheurs qui y
accède à ses archives pour leurs travaux
le fait de travailler avec des méthodes
numériques sur un corpus qui
traditionnellement sont ceux des
sciences humaines c'est la grande
famille de recherche qui maintenance
appelle les digital humanities les
humanités numériques c'est apporter les
outils informatiques aux travaux de
sciences humaines pour travailler sur
des gros corpus le projet haute et
médias l'objectif c'est de regarder plus
particulièrement les news les
informations et la façon dont
l'écosystème médiatique travail
fonctionne et créer les news et la
manière dont ces news se propager la
manière dont elles sont consommées on
essaye de faire en sorte avec cette
plate forme de pouvoir avoir les données
de l'intégralité de l'écosystème bien
sûr la télé la radio mais également la
presse les agences de presse et réseaux
sociaux donc notamment avec twitter et à
l'intérieur de cet écosystème réussir à
modéliser un certain nombre de
phénomènes sur comment est ce que par
exemple les choix éditoriaux sont fait
qu'elle va être l'influencent delà des
chaînes d'informations en continu sur
les la presse traditionnelle comment est
ce que twitter va relayer ce qui est dit
à la télévision
al'inverse comment est ce que les
journalistes observent ce qui se dit sur
twitter pour faire leurs choix
éditoriaux pour hiérarchiser
informations vous la mesure du temps de
parole des hommes et des femmes à la
télé la radio c'est un sujet qui
traitait depuis plusieurs années il ya
un projet actuellement menée par david
duke angem gender equality monitor qui a
pour but justement de quantifier les
temps de parole et on sait que les
femmes sont moins présentes que les
hommes dans les médias la question étant
de pouvoir finalement à un moment donné
poser un chiffre et dire oui mais dans
quelle ampleur
est-ce que ça se dégrade est-ce que ça
s'améliore un algorithme a été
développée qui est capable de distinguer
lorsqu'il entend une voix si c'est un
homme ou une femme qui parle l'intérêt
de ces travaux qui va être bien sûr de
documenter 2
mieux comprendre ce qui se passe mais là
on est typiquement dans un sujet de
société qui implique des choix de
société qui implique le politique ni à
un moment donné c'est le rôle notamment
du csa de faire en sorte que ces
chiffres s'améliorent qui puisse y avoir
une meilleure représentation des femmes
dans les médias ces travaux là et sont
utilisés par les autorités par les
pouvoirs publics pour essayer de faire
en sorte que les choses s'améliorent